hey guys dr. Burke here in this video I
want to share with you what to do if you
have varicose veins now I will tell you
that most herbal remedies most vitamins
for varicose veins just don't work I've
tried so many different remedies and you
just end up it's expensive urine it just
doesn't seem to correct it I'm going to
show you what does correct it but let's
just first explain what the veins do now
veins carry blood from your extremities
your fingers and your toes all the way
back up to the heart okay so the heart
pushes blood through the artery system
and then the veins bring it back to the
heart so it's a returned blood flow and
one of the biggest differentiation from
arteries to veins is veins don't have
the assistance of the heart as a pump
okay so arteries can just take LA the
heart to pump blood through the body but
veins need your muscles to contract to
push the blood back to the heart so if
you're too inactive and you're not
exercising and you're sitting all day
chances are you're going to develop some
varicose veins or spider veins okay now
there's other causes of varicose veins
as well especially from pregnancy
that's an estrogen problem it's also
when you have developing this baby this
huge mass in your abdomen
you could cut off circulation you can
have the excess weight that puts
pressure on those veins and also you
have the relationship between estrogen
and the side effect one of the side
effects is spider veins or varicose
veins okay so that could be a situation
too so really the solution is to get out
there and start exercising okay it's as
simple as that you want to start doing
walking workouts on a consistent basis
now depending how bad the problem is
like some people have really bad
varicosities or varicose veins that they
might need to have those removed okay
because you have other veins that can
take up the slack but if it's a medium
problem or it's an easier issue
exercise should handle it but it takes
like a year to two years to correct that
it's not going to happen overnight so
that's one thing now for spider veins
that's a little bit different you want
to do the same thing but one of the
interesting things
nutritionally that will cause a spider
vein is excessive vitamin C now I'm not
talking about the food based vitamin C
I'm talking about a set excessive
ascorbic acid which is synthetic vitamin
C so people that do grams of ascorbic
acid actually create deficiencies in the
other vitamin C complex
normally vitamin C has many parts to it
and so when you buy vitamin C from the
health of store what you're really
getting in most cases is a bunch of
synthetic ascorbic acid specially if
it's like 500 milligrams or more if
that's the case just realize you're
buying something that's made from
cornstarch in sulfuric acid there's
really no vitamin C in there okay so
they sometime I don't know who did this
but they change the name of ascorbic
acid to being vitamin C when it's really
one little fraction of the vitamin C
complex the best source of vitamin C is
from food or food concentrates so you
want to do a lot of vegetables and
things like that okay so if you want to
correct spider veins you just want a lot
more vitamin C foods in the diet over a
long period of time okay and avoid any
type of ascorbic acid synthetic vitamin
C so what's your next step get out there
start walking start exercising on a
regular basis and that will correct the
pooling of the varicose veins
a normal vein you have this straight
shot the blood returns back to the heart
in a varicose vein it pulls the valves
get loose it becomes enlarged and then
you get pooling of blood which could
create problems with strokes as well so
we want to go from here to here start
exercising start walking I will see you
in the next video